that's actually a good story to tell
about how David got into Atlantis yeah
yeah that's true I mean yeah By ignoring
the casting agents
Direction there was nearly no McKay in
Stargate
Atlantis could you even imagine such a
thing
inconceivable you keep using the word I
don't know think it means what you think
it
means I'm just going to let that sink in
for a second and even more than that
Stargate Atlantis nearly didn't happen
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel so what what nonsense is
this that Rodney McCay was nearly not in
Stargate Atlantis that's actually a good
story to tell about how David got into
Atlantis yeah yeah that's true I mean
yeah By ignoring the casting agents
Direction no I do you not even know this
story I know some of the story but you
should yeah let's hear it let's hear it
the character that a lot of people loved
more than any other David huet has
become a Sci-Fi God to many of us and an
absolute Legend and McKay for me was my
favorite character it would not have
been anything like the same show without
him well I mean David's character wasn't
in the show when we were casting um he
uh we we spent a good deal of time C in
fact I I you you started after we
started shooting didn't you like I it
was the last cast you were cast after we
started shooting yeah yeah yeah now
obviously Rodney McCay the character of
Rodney McCay had appeared in sg1 and I'd
always thought of assumed really that it
was always the plan for him to go into
SGA that they were just sort of grooming
him or at very least that he was so
brilliant in sg1 which let's be honest
he was that I've always thought he was
the first name on the sheet you know the
executives would have been actually
screaming get David huet it always sort
of made me think about sort of the fifth
season of
Angel follow me I have a point that
actually Spike's character died at the
end of Buffy but the executives were
desperate to get the character in Angel
because he was so popular so they
actually forced Sweden to do it and Jos
Sweden had to like fire chrisma
Carpenter because of it because they
couldn't afford all the actors I've
always assumed there was a similar thing
to that that it was sort of like when
they started talking about doing
starcade Atlantis they was like we'd
really love that Rodney M guy David
huet's great build a show around him um
but no that is not the case at all so on
a recent interview over on the companion
Brad Wright Robert Cooper and David huet
T talked about this very issue and they
talked about David huet's character they
actually talked about the Genesis of
Rodney
McCay they talked about the lemons the
writer who was on the show for a short
period of
time who claimed he was mortally
allergic to lemon and really oh that's
where that came from uh and we we the
story was we used to go to um Brad's
Brad's favorite restaurant swis Chalet
for lunch
yeah and this guy on several occasions
would ask the the the server uh you know
is there is there lemon in the
sauce because I'm more than
lemon morally allergic and and for the
longest time you know the server like no
no there's no lemon in that and so we
went on like that for some time then
another time we went back and he did it
again you know he asked the question and
the Ser was like oh oh yes of course
there is it's like 50% lemon he was
eating this sauce with the with the
lemon in it for for months now I
absolutely endore that the character was
sort of created out of Robert Cooper's
brain because of the way people thought
about him uh the writer's room used to
kind of mock me a little bit about what
I would do and say in the writer room
what you rob yeah um they said I had it
look and they also said they said Brad
would often you know say his joke was uh
that I would comment you know I didn't
hear anything you were saying but while
you were talking and then I would say my
idea uh and and so I just wrote that
character and everybody's like oh he's
such a great villain and I was like
interesting in some ways McKay is Cooper
and David Huer obvious talks about how
he felt that actually was a morphing of
between Brad Wright and Robert Cooper
and you know Brad Wright wrote a lot of
the character so of course it would be
and would reflect elements of his own
personality in there perhaps but also
Brad Wright has talked a lot about how
he would watch actors and that he would
try to bring a lot of their own
mannerisms into a character and let's be
honest David huet was McKay I've watched
David huet in interviews Etc and on his
podcasts and on his streaming for years
and every so often he sounds like McKay
he's obviously a massive geek he's a
nerd he is one of us but also there is a
little bit of an I want to say arrogance
but it's not really it's it's a Swagger
about him something that him and McKay
did share now McKay's obviously
was on a different level but it does
seem to me that David huet does have a
little bit of a Ting of Robert McKay to
his
personality so there you have it when
when they started filming they hadn't
cast David huet they still had this
Ingram character completely different
character in mind for the team ask from
the network or at least it wasn't
explicit but you kind of felt like well
we want something new we want it to be
all fresh and different and so bringing
like Legacy characters over um you know
was maybe not our first thought but you
know when we went through the the
casting process we realized nobody was
as good as David
there wasn't a McKay Brad Wright was
talking about how oh we just want that
sort of character but the executives
over at sci-fi wouldn't let them do it
they wouldn't let them cast the person
they wanted in the end they got David
hulet to actually go to a casting
director and do a read for the Ingram
character but he kept doing it as M and
the the casting agent kept saying like
ah it's to McKay it's to McKay and I
would say I'd go like oh really well
whoever his manager is I actually want
to punch them in the testicles with a
ice pick our our choices you know one
two three four and then they huddled up
and rank their choices and our 1234 was
their
43 if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com citrek
where most of our new videos Premiere
first and you get to see them without
the adverts you lucky bunnies also
finally you can go to c.co which is our
dedicated website and we write articles
based on a lot of our videos and we try
to add a little bit more information for
you to digest go and check it out as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next
[Music]
time